[Music]
look denied defense by smart
curry
man he had to work for that bucket jeff
game one
three for 17 performance saying hey kobe
bryant your guy
had 11 games under 40 percent
rooney
for the slam easy in july
amen
i love this play by steph curry draw the
attention and simply make guys around
you better seven seconds to go for curry
on pritchett
ty's hedging
curry in his bag got it
[Applause]
and more resistance in a practice shot
than that
curry out of the timeout
good way to settle things down and
peyton on tatum
good aggressive show and switch by green
and they get the turnover
step for three
both these teams really handsy on
defense
[Applause]
inside to wiggins
terrific play by curry but a
well-timed cut by wigan hey mark well
imeidoka said what he didn't like about
that first half was boston's 11
turnovers he said we had seven when i
talked to you after the first
[Applause]
curry working against horford took his
ankles
not ready to give him back either
coverage
he walks into a
three
natum spins right into draymond green
pritchard from deep with two on the
clock
golden state with another stop trying to
close out this third quarter better than
they did in game one
oh but look on the screen
poor otto porter with a tice is dropping
you cannot guard him like that you have
to be up if you're tight
and the answer look i'm in position
coach look at my stance that's not going
to work you might as well be in the
paint you must be on the bench with me
getting into the paint
hurry against white
very drives good health defense from
grant williams but not good enough on a
gorgeous
banker there from steph curry eight
offensive boards for the celtics
[Applause]
curry
drives ontario gets inside the beautiful
left hand
and curry's drive as mark said good job
getting to that left hand
warriors you got to do a better job of
containing the basketball
curry step back jumper got it
14 points for curry
[Applause]
curry long three pointer it's good and
the foul steph curry with a chance for a
four point play
and the lead is cut to six
we'll pick up the foul his second
that's a flagrant foul
by the way they do it
al hoffman not up high enough
curry launches a three pucks it in step
and he is elevating versus
trying to draw contact and fouls
sorry
steps back two pointer for curry that's
good steph curry
just with a foot on the line
[Applause]
trying to fight through that screen slow
to get up
off the offensive rebound wiggins nobody
near him connects on a three
gives curry
the space he needs and then looney
terrific offensive rebound
curry drives it
and a nice play to wiggins
much needed offense from somebody else
and wiggins has provided gary payton
pokes it away peyton the elite defender
off the bench
curry steps back three-pointer got it
steph curry his first three absolutely
does looking good
feeling good
searching out al hoffman that possession
[Applause]
curry another long distance shot it's
good steph curry
back-to-back long-distance threes and a
five-point lead for the warriors
celtics call timeout
waits for the screen to roll off it
again in the picture
not in position you allow steph curry to
come up and see the basket
there's a price to pay and he lets
with a beautiful move and off the glass
they don't really have a roll game
sorry gets free get some contact land
got it and one steph curry felt the bump
brown picks up his third and a chance
for a three-point play he is a unique
individual and a gifted
along with the all-time greats talent
and that's strength right there too
playing through
the contact of jalen brown
that's what steve kerr was so upset with
in game three he said we just didn't box
out they got crushed on the boards
[Music]
here's the shot we're talking about
you're right robin williams got to
affect steph curry coming off that
screen but good job by derek white
fighting over the screen
and contestant
lineup it's wiggits
[Applause]
and maybe some second shots
curry again oh steph curry from way down
down he's furious
[Applause]
and that's contact that's a foul he
should have been shooting a free throw
that's a ridiculous shot
no why don't you concentrate on al
horpitz he should be up that guy he's
amazing oh my goodness
curry fakes
smart nearly takes it away
and curry will bring it back out smart
harassing
[Applause]
curry now has williams on him looking to
unload it
flips it up shot is good
that the warriors can beat the green and
white in boston well
the point god did
that's steph curry getting on the
offensive end
[Music]
they've had some good looks but the
threes won't go down as curry comes the
other way
curry to green
[Applause]
[Music]
back to curry step back three-pointer
steph curry drills the three that's a
six-point warriors lead time-out boston
but mike again it happened because they
pushed the ball
compacted the defense curry was able
to get just enough room from white
to knock in another incredible shot
[Music]
williams has been invaluable really if
both ends doesn't score a lot of points
but his presence makes a big difference
draymond green lays it up and in here's
what you're talking about in the
get draymond green to dive instead of
standing on that three-point line and
steph curry does a great job taking
but i love the physical nature of it and
the team spirit what's icing i don't
know that's when they chuck it way down
the court perry chucks it up and puts it
in
brown drives on green
stolen by payton
lost it momentarily shuffles it ahead to
curry
[Music]
curry to wiggins wiggins the layout
carelessness by the celtics but give
credit to the warriors active hands
comes up with the steal defense to
offense curry finds a slashing diving
wiggins
for the easy deuce
so white scores a nuggets fan growing up
love carmelo anthony loved chauncey
phillips when he was in denver
as curry drives layup off the glass is
good another one of those they've
imposed their will defensively against
his warrior team
curry looking for some room but brown on
them curry the drive throws it up and
ahead what a beautiful floater
now some good action after what was kind
of a ragged first half
curry shuffle pass payton the layup is
good frame on green
eric white no hesitation can't answer
curry runs in and grabs the board
[Applause]
curry to peyton
three-quarter right side is good
[Applause]
they've got nine offensive rebounds
already here in the first half
perry sees some room nails a three steps
how about steph curry
gets white in the air
fly by
makes him pay the price
we're witnessing greatness
that's saying a lot he's been all over
the floor on both sides of the court
had a good game five but an excellent
start here in six steph curry once again
dancing and prancing in the paint and
elite is 16 largest of the first half
the delivery on point how about steph
curry dance young man dance flat out
getting it done in the season comes in
bank shot in and out robert williams had
it but lost it draymond green pushing
green stops
[Applause]
clay thompson
curry sidestep three-pointer it's guards
and the previous play moving without the
rocks draymond green does his job
setting the screen top of the backboard
which is in bounds and draymond green
pushing
six assists for green
curry along three that's good steph
curry from way downtown some curry chaos
here in the third it's the largest lead
of the game curry has done his entire
life he's got nine of his 21 here in the
third quarter five of six from
three-point range warriors up big and
they love it back in san francisco
19 points 14 rebounds for horford
but you're switching for no reason that
wasn't even a screen marcus smart bails
out and forces ala harper to defend kurt
curry against horford gets pass him
inside off the glass again
and so he's going one on one and like
they're just staring at